c'est pas normal qu'aujourd'hui on est
des gens qui doivent choisir entre faire
l'épicerie bien payer le loyer est vrai
de dire que les québécois
s'appauvrissent comme le laisse entendre
dominique enghelab
[Musique]
attention c'est une affirmation qui
méritent d'être nuancés
selon statistique canada l'inflation a
grimpé de 7,3 pour cent au québec entre
juillet 2021 et juillet 2022 ça va
peut-être vous surprendre mais les
salaires ont progressé un peu plus
rapidement le salaire horaire moyen a
grimpé de 8% dans la province pendant la
même période
pour l'ensemble du canada c'est le
scénario inverse
l'inflation a bondi de 7,6 pour cent
mais les salaires n'ont grimpé que de
5,2 pour cent au cours de la dernière
année il faut dire que la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qui est très importante au
québec exerce une pression à la hausse
sur les salaires mais ce n'est pas tout
le monde qui en profite
si le salaire des cadres supérieurs a
bondi de 56% et celui des infirmières de
10% dans la dernière année celui des
vendeurs et du personnel dans les
secteurs des arts et spectacles et des
sports et loisirs a plutôt fait du
surplace bon nombre de syndiqués dont le
salaire est déterminé par une convention
collective n'ont pas vu leurs revenus
augmenter ou si rapidement que
l'inflation et les gens qui ont des
revenus fixes comme les retraités ou les
bénéficiaires de l'aide sociale voient
leur pouvoir d'achat diminuer en ce
moment alors oui les gens
s'appauvrissent mais c'est loin d'être
le cas de l'ensemble des québécois